this episode is sponsored by ren a
website where you calculate your carbon
emissions you can sign up to make a
monthly contribution to offset your
emissions or support rainforest
protection projects by clicking our link
in the description
[Music]
tardigrades have been through a lot
they've been sent to the moon they've
had the moisture sapped out of them at
times they've been in extreme heat and
at other times they've had to contend
with extreme cold and they have borne
all of this with as much a dignity as a
creature nicknamed moss piglet can not
knowing that on the other side would be
a whole audience of scientists and
microscopy fans waiting to hear about
the latest achievement in tardigrade
survival that they have managed to
unlock
well today we've got a new one for you a
harrowing journey of these tardigrades
that have taken them through what we
assume must be the worst thing that
tardigrades have yet to be subjected to
these poor enduring tarnigrades got
stuck
in postal security
their journey through the macro cosmos
began in a much more idyllic place a
beach in portugal these are marine
tardigrades which we've never been able
to show on our channel before for the
very simple reason that we'd never found
them before
sadly there is not much information
available about marine tardigrades
compared to freshwater ones so we will
not be able to dive too deep into their
lives today but we can watch their
strange gecko-like feet as they walk
across the slide and appreciate that
they are indeed very
very weird to look at and james our
master of microscopes had been searching
for marine tardigrades in the various
sand samples he gets from the baltic sea
but he couldn't find any perhaps because
the water wasn't salty enough he'd even
trawled through coral farm samples to
find them but still no luck but then
james reached out to a marine biologist
friend in portugal named maria and asked
if she could send some portugal beach
samples along you know the usual favors
between friends so maria went to the
beach following james's instructions as
she dug through the sand at different
phases of the tide and gathered algae
and biofilm from the rocks then she
packed up the samples in a box and sent
them in the mail
within that box not yet known to either
its sender or receiver were these
batillopes tardigrades
batillopes is a genus of marine
tardigrades and ironically given how
difficult they have been for james to
find the first petillopes darted grains
were actually found in the baltic sea
and since then there have been at least
36 species described
we don't know exactly what species these
petilipes are but they do strongly
resemble a species called batillopes
minius that was discovered in northern
portugal in 2015
and what was striking to james when he
first saw them is just how small they
are he'd been expecting them to be much
larger more on the order of their
freshwater relatives like this one which
at 200x looks giant compared to the
petilipes but james did not know that
these adorable little tardigrades were
on route to him when maria sent him
those samples from the beach they were
just hypothetical little worlds teeming
with unknown and unseen life
and then those hypothetical little
worlds got stuck in germany for security
reasons
why
no idea the microcosmos often has us
shrugging and saying
we have no idea to its many mysteries
and i suppose that mirrors the reality
of the macro cosmos as well because
sometimes you find out your package full
of beach sand is going to be stuck in a
german warehouse for the weekend and all
you can do
is shrug
after someone opened everything up and
checked that it had been declared
correctly the package and our
tardigrades were able to resume their
journey and make it to james's doorstep
but unfortunately
the lack of oxygen meant that the algae
samples were not able to survive their
delay to the warehouse
but that would never stop james from
trying to find whatever he can in these
samples so he spent 16 straight hours
looking through them
and to his delight the sand samples had
a whole herd of petilipees wandering
around in them having survived a
spectacular journey they never could
have known
they were on
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us and thank you again to
ren for sponsoring this episode ren is a
website where you can calculate your
carbon emissions then offset it by
funding projects like mineral weathering
in scotland or providing clean burning
fuel and cook stoves to refugees in
uganda we will need a lot of different
approaches to stop the climate crisis
and this is just one way you can learn
more about your carbon contribution and
take some action
you will answer a few questions about
your lifestyle and they will show you
ways you can start reducing your carbon
emissions now no one can reduce their
footprint to zero but using ren you can
help offset what you have left once you
sign up you'll receive updates from the
tree planting rainforest protection or
other projects you support and we've
partnered with rem to plant 10
additional trees for the first 100
people who sign up using our link in the
description
the people on the screen right now are
the real heroes of this story except for
of course whoever it was in germany who
decided that yes indeed james could have
his tardigrades also the tardigrades are
an additional hero in the story there's
a lot of heroes because there's a lot of
stories but we are extremely grateful to
these folks right here they are our
patreon patrons and if you want to be a
reason why this channel exists you can
check it out at patreon.com
journey2micro if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes james
weiss you can check out jam and germs on
instagram and if you want to see more
from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
[Music]
you